Christy gnome says leave your Tick Tock
at home but Apple tells the CCP your
repression is fine with me South Dakota
Governor Christie gnome signed an
executive order that bans government
employees from having tick tock on any
state device adding quote the Chinese
Communist Party uses information it
gathers on Tick Tock to manipulate the
American people you know which is much
easier than having sex with Eric
swalwell and less risky than hiring
Hunter Biden
she didn't say that I did just to be
clear this is in Stark opposition to
Biden's policy which is repeatedly
tapped Tick Tock stars for campaign
videos to manipulate the American people
into thinking he's doing a good job
which makes sense it's the best place to
reach people dumb enough to vote for him
meanwhile Apple reportedly restricted
the use of airdrop in China earlier this
month airdrop allows phones to connect
to each other without the internet which
helps bypass censorship while sharing
info about lockdown protests or get a
traffic update on tanks coming through
Tiananmen Square
previously users could receive airdrops
from anyone for an unlimited time but a
new update limits this to just 10
minutes for phones bought in mainland
China
like Taylor Swift writing all those
breakup songs after I dumped her
it's hard to believe this is a
coincidence and it's a huge issue I mean
why would Apple want to hurt the Chinese
Freedom protesters it's not like they're
Canadian Truckers
and they're the same adults that buy
their products unlike the children who
work in their factories
[Music]
that's used to talk
I wish really you're too old no
like
and again I keep coming back yes uh no I
because I would actually be really good
at it yeah and just like little make
little funny videos and get a bunch of
attention which is my favorite thing
attention right so I would love to do it
but then I'm worried about like the
whole like Chinese and the data or
whatever so it's interesting like that I
do draw a line somewhere right for what
I'll do for attention and apparently
that's it we'll see I think for now I
think when you're talking about
attention Tom that's how China figured
us out we are addicted to attention and
so Tick Tock is now kind of like My
Favorite Drug it is yeah people love it
tick tock kind of packages it for
everybody and it's an effective
brainwashing tool because then everybody
you have uh people with crazy attitudes
getting on there and just spreading it
out there and getting into your house
it's a brainwashing tool that has
entered your home they attacked us at
our weak point Greg yes because we love
these things and the kids do I I got to
give it to Chris Christie gnome for
doing this I I think it's great I think
they should just ban it for everybody
never mind on state devices that's not
going to do much but she could actually
I mean if there's any politician who
could actually do well on Tick Tock it's
probably Christy gnome she could do the
dances with the 10 gallon hat and
everything like that but uh yeah
that's what I'm talking about
so she's giving up a lot she's giving up
a potential Tick Tock uh career here but
I think uh yeah tick tock's ridiculous
we should shame anyone who does it
especially adults I'm sick of these
parents dancing with their kids hey
let's do a tick tock video it's like
shut up yes
sit down you idiot let your kids do it
but not you I like it when you get mad
you still don't swear he's like you just
go shut up well Greg why don't you bleep
my shut up and everyone think I swear it
at home
foreign
[Applause]
you're the expert on China you've
written two books your new book which is
fiction by the way but it's it's on
China uh and when you're looking at
what's happening now everybody gets
hopeful and then it looks really scary
because all these guys at hazmat suits
with Plexiglas where is this going you
think well first of all gosh darn it Tom
look China we have to be we have to
become grown-ups about China China's not
our friend
um Tick Tock is owned by a Chinese
company
China is owned by the Communist Party of
China so therefore anything that you put
on Tick Tock is going straight to Xi
Jinping not that he cares about you and
it's being kept China keeps meticulous
records of the movements of the
statements of the social media postings
and even now of eye movements of its
citizens and then it decides whether
they're loyal to the party or not or
whether they need a good smacking yeah
Governor gnome has done exactly the
right thing she started with State
accounts and I think she's to be
credited for it we'll call it the new
nomenclature yeah ah nice
little word play Jamie
yeah well I was gonna tell a cute story
about a song I did with my son on tick
tock
it sucks how when was the last time you
saw your son Tom made me feel stupid
I missed that um so Tick Tock they say I
heard it's called Tick Tock because you
can is the clock counting down to when
the Chinese will have all your
information
um they said I go well but doesn't
everybody get our information like
aren't they getting it from other places
and someone said to me if they get all
your information like they can get your
you they can take out like home loans or
you know whatever borrow money and like
steal your identity and I was like oh my
God good luck because I haven't been
able to do it
um that would suck if somebody was my
own got a home loan yeah because I can't
none of that stuff's gonna well they're
gonna they're gonna give my identity
back yeah
I don't I'm getting irritated at Apple
just with all the you know just like the
you know Twitter stuff and they're
always trying to get you to I try to
like fight the up I just updated to uh
six like iOS 16 last night I updated and
on my screen saver just says Elon Musk
what I said was for people that didn't
see it I said shut up
I don't know man the apps might be gone
because phones are so fast now you might
not need apps anymore your phone has a
screen saver
oh
here we go
that's it I'm too old to know the words
he's just being some older men hanging
out
waiting that's what I do and people say
what do you do for a living that's
pretty well that's kind of Aegis
it's true all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else